now of course one of the bigger stories
at the minute is this allegation that
Dominic Cummings the most senior advisor
to the Prime Minister travelled to
Durham while his wife was suffering with
Kovac 19 to stay with family and is what
mr. Cummings did safe well clearly not
and that he undermined the core public
health messages which was to stay home
to make sure that children were not left
with elderly relatives and also going
from an area which had which was a head
of the country London to an area which
was bit behind which was northeast
England and his North East England is
now one of the hardest hit parts of the
country so the clear thing I would like
to say is yes he needs to resign but we
need to also move on and refocus on the
key issues facing the UK which is the UK
now has close to 60,000 excess deaths
one of the worst deaths rates per capita
in the world we're in a lockdown we
don't have a good way out of this
lockdown because there's no testing and
tracing infrastructure to let us safely
lift the lockdown and we have a lot of
people suffering because of a lack of
clear strategy of how we're going to
move forward and get out of the deep
hole that we're in one of these
successes has been getting the public to
obey the stay at home message you
concern that with the defence of Dominic
Cummings there's almost been a
suggestion that the rules of a lockdown
er open to interpretation and what the
consequences of that could be definitely
I think right now the key message still
needs to remained you know follow the
regulations of the government you should
not let one person to track from the
larger message but also that we really
need to be thinking who's bearing that
taking the sacrifices and bearing the
brunt of this lockdown and it seems
unfair that there's one set of rules if
you belong to a certain part of society
and another set of rules if you don't
and I think possibly the government's
misread the public reading on us because
it's not a political issue at all this
is about right and wrong a public health
response and trying to get through a
crisis where every single person in the
country is affected I mean do you think
that the lockdown is beginning to fray
now anyway certainly anecdotally it
feels that there's lots more people
meeting up well it's understandable were
eight to nine weeks into a lockdown and
a lot of people are bearing the price of
this and I think this does points to
what has fundamentally changed over the
last eight
weeks during the lockdown other
countries went into lockdown rapidly
they used a lockdown to drive down the
number of cases I'm thinking of Germany
Denmark Norway New Zealand Australia
Greece then once they've driven down the
number of cases they know they can
safely lift the lockdown because they're
testing and tracing systems can take
over the hard work of suppressing the
virus and so that society can resume
kids can get back in school businesses
can reopen shops can reopen and I'm
looking now and we're in May and we've
been discussing testing and tracing
since February South Korea has been
doing this in January and I'm just
wondering what is fundamentally changed
over the lockdown and I guess that's
also leading to fatigue one of the big
decisions of course is when to reopen
schools on June the 1st it's expected or
they're not confirmed that nurseries and
some primary aged children will go back
to school do you think it's safe for
children to do so and is it safe for
teachers to do so well I think I'd have
to break down the question to say is it
safe enough what is the threshold of
risk that's acceptable and I think the
three principles to follow with schools
are first to be completely honest and
transparent with teachers and parents
about the scientific uncertainty we know
children carry the virus we don't know
the degree they transmit it to adults we
also don't yet know how rare it is for
children to have this delayed
inflammatory multi syndrome condition
which means that several weeks after
exposure to the virus they have a severe
inflammatory reaction the second thing
is we need to have monitoring in place
testing tracing and the ability to break
chains of transmission and identify
quickly clusters in schools
Germany is actually testing kids as they
come in to school to make sure they
catch cases as fast as they emerge and
the third is we need local level
decision-making in data in some parts of
the country we look at local authorities
there's thousands of daily cases look at
the northeast of England and other parts
there are a few dozen it obviously makes
a difference whether you are going to
open a school when there's a lot of
community transmission or where there's
very little so we need local level data
and decision making and possibly a
system of green orange red to let
parents and teachers and the community
know of what the level of transmission
is like in your particular community an
interesting idea that one and you're
talking about the need to use data it
does feel as if the are number or the
rate of infection how many people each
infect a person passes coded 19 onto is
really been linked to the easing of a
lockdown do you think that's the right
measure to use I think there's been too
much emphasis on our as one metric to
try to determine how to actually manage
to lock down the real basic question is
how do you suppress the virus as the
lockdown lifts what is the package of
interventions you need to drive the
virus down to a safe enough level that
people can emerge and circulate and
socialize and there I think the
questions we need to be asking are how
many daily new cases are there in a
particular area also the our number as
well but also what is a testing and
tracing capability like is it working is
it up and running so I think we need to
have a more package of interventions
that are monitored across a number of
metrics